SOLEIL KELLEY: Hello and
welcome to Cloud OnAir Live
Webinars for Google Cloud.
My name is Soleil
Kelley, and I'm
a product marketer on Google
Cloud, specifically focused
on data visualization and
business intelligence.
And joining me is--
DAVE OLESON: I'm Dave Oleson, a
product manager at Google Data
Studio.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Great.
Keep in mind, you
can ask questions
at any time throughout
this presentation.
We have some Googlers on
standby to answer them,
and we'll have a live Q&A at
the end of the presentation.
Next slide please.
So today I'm very
excited to be talking
about data and specifically how
we're communicating the data
and how that's really
changed over time.
Data is so much more embedded
in our day-to-day lives
and woven into the fabric
of our conversations.
And it's really-- it's
just interesting how
it's changed so much over time.
And this is not just
internally throughout business
in organizations but externally
to public audiences online.
It's just interesting times.
And then, of course,
this wouldn't be complete
if we didn't actually
build a demo.
So we're going to also
create a demo here onscreen
for everybody.
So long before we had
these incredible devices
in our hands, we were--
we were pulling insights
from all kinds of places.
I'm looking at this photograph
of a campfire in the Pacific
Northwest and thinking
about just way back
when to find insights.
If you were, say,
a fisherman, you
would take stock of
your day's catch.
You would weave in
stories that were passed
over the generations
across that campfire
to create some
insights that you might
use to figure out
what you're going
to do in your very next day.
Fast forwarding to technology
today and where we're at,
all these incredible
innovations have
made it so easy for us
to be able to take data
from disparate places and weave
them together into these really
compelling stories so.
A single person might be
taking and matching data
from NOAA weather
data and boat traffic
and potentially some
aquatic survey data
and creating this compelling
story line, sharing it out.
Maybe it's a story
about sustainability.
So really the way in which we
can tell these stories online
has just dramatically changed.
And that's just--
it's super exciting.
To do this even 10--
5 or 10 years ago, it used
to take a lot of people
to actually create
these stories.
Today we know it can be done
much more single-handedly.
But again, 10 years
ago, you would need IT.
You would need data scientists
potentially, some really
hardcore analysts, maybe some
developers for the front end,
even designers to
stand up the story,
and to be able to
push that online.
And that doesn't even
mean maintaining it.
To do that, you would need a
lot of resources like time.
You would need a lot of
budget to do that as well.
And that becomes
really challenging.
Today we-- we've introduced a
product a couple of years ago.
It's called Data
Studio, again which Dave
is as a product manager for.
DAVE OLESON: Can you
pass [INAUDIBLE]??
SOLEIL KELLEY: And it's
really a product that is--
it's a free product.
It's really designed for
people who analyze and work
with data every day who are
analyzing and communicating
that data out designed from
the ground up to really make it
super easy to visualize,
to work with the data
and also to share that out.
It's completely
serverless and scalable
across Google's
entire infrastructure.
So that makes it
really easy for you
to focus on the things that
matter most to you, which
is telling stories.
And so what we've really
done with Data Studio
is simplify the whole
process and the workflow.
So if you think about accessing
and connecting to your data,
that process of analyzing it,
visualizing it, and sharing
that out, we've really
simplified that process.
And so if we think about
the data sources, that's
one of the most common scenarios
that people are asking about
is how I connect to
this data or that data?
And you can see on the screen
so many different sources
on both from the
Google side if you
have your data stored in
places like BigQuery or GCS
to even other places like
your ad performance data, tons
of different
first-party Google data
as well as a ton of sources
available from our fast-growing
community of data connections.
So over 300 sources,
everything from Reddit
to Salesforce to Facebook
and many other companies,
developers are building these
connections to new sources.
And that really means that
you have a lot more access
to the data that you
care about and what
you want to be able
to tell in your story.
Also worth mentioning on this
is the access that you have.
Within BigQuery, we have
all of these public data
sets that you can use to be able
to weave into your own stories
or to be able to
create new insights,
as well as there are
commercial data sets
that you can license as well.
And once you're all set and
done, you've built the story
and you found those
insights, it's
super easy to be
able to share that
out to your audiences
and your stakeholders,
either just a link to a report,
if that might be internally
if you want to keep your data
protected and just share that
link internally, nobody
else would have access
to it, or as an iFrame embedded
in your blog or your website,
something like that.
So I mentioned we're going
to build a demo today.
And so, of course, we will be
doing that and just sending
a little bit of
context for this demo.
This is a particular story
about a marketing team's success
drafted by the team lead.
Her name is Maya, and
she works at a company
called Foo Hardware.
She wanted to send out a
pre-read ahead of a quarterly
all hands.
And so just a simple
scenario of hey,
I really want to motivate
people to get to this quarterly
all hands because attendance
has been really low.
She wanted everybody to see the
success of a couple of programs
that her team had been running
and specifically because it
had broad implications around
an opportunity for Foo Hardware.
She leads marketing programs
for all West Coast departments
of Foo.
And despite being
traditional brick and mortar,
they stay pretty current
with new technologies.
One of their analysts recently
brought in a bunch of data
into BigQuery.
Maya hadn't heard of it.
She wasn't too familiar with it.
She spends most of her
time in their CRM focusing
on their customers and whatnot.
So this is the story that
Maya actually sent out.
This was in the form of a link.
Again, this is an
internal story,
so this is not something--
this is the Foo Hardware's
data they want to protect.
They're not going to be
broadcasting this out
online for everybody to see.
So this is really
an internal story
that she's sharing here
directly within Google Studio.
And so again she
starts her story
with just those key
metrics that she
knows everybody wants to see.
Everything is going great.
And she invites people to
go dive in and take a look
at the actual data itself.
So here first she
builds a very--
an overview, a very basic
dashboard of company health,
looking at the past year,
departmental revenues, couple
of score cards for
profit and profit margin,
and time series of how profit--
how revenue was done
over the last year.
And again this is
interactive so people
could be in here and playing
with the date controls
and whatnot if they wanted to.
So to her audience, she is
taking them down this path.
She's telling a story
because, again, she
wants to get them to
this quarterly alliance.
So everything's
looking good right?
But did you know Foo is sitting
on this massive opportunity.
Let's take a look at
another slice of the data,
looking at our top five states.
So she creates a stack
bar looking at revenue
across the past year broken by
month for the top five states,
and she also included a
couple of filters so people
in other departments--
again she leads departments
on the west coast territory.
But if other folks wanted
to drill in and see
their own data,
they could do that.
And here, again, guiding
them down the path.
So what specific
opportunity am I
trying to find here as
the consumer of the story?
Paint me a picture.
Tell me what's going on.
So here she then
lays out you know
hey our team piloted
this marketing
initiative in the spring,
specifically around paint,
across all the
geographies in California.
So let's take a look at
those specific results.
And so here she drills
into just specific paint.
She added a filter
for this report
just to see the
revenues for paints,
and you can see very well that
in that springtime revenue
was flying high.
So it was doing
really, really well.
People might have questions.
Well, is this repeatable?
And she anticipates
that and takes them down
this path again.
So they're also
running this program
in appliances at the same time.
So here she's showing those
results that hey, this
is working in appliances, too.
And that's fantastic,
so as the audience,
she knows they have
a lot of questions.
And so she once again to
bring them to the quarterly
all hands where her team can
share the successes and really
dive into the details
of how they achieve that
and how they can unlock this
opportunity for Foo Hardware.
So again real basic
story, and that's
our story completely
built in Data Studio.
And next Dave is going
to help us walk through
how Maya built this experience.
DAVE OLESON: Great.
Thanks, Soleil.
So I'll show how we helped Maya
build this great experience
in Data Studio.
So this is the Data Studio home
page, and there's reports--
there's a list of all
the reports that I have--
and then data sources.
And data sources
are just connections
to my underlying data.
So I come over here on the left.
I click on Data Sources.
These are my existing
data sources,
but I want to create
a new data source.
And so like Soleil
mentioned, we have connectors
to many different data.
So we have Google performance,
adds performance connectors
like AdWords YouTube,
Google Analytics.
We have Cloud connectors like
Google Cloud Storage, BigQuery,
Cloud SQL.
And then we also have more
third-party connectors
where users can
come in and actually
build their own connectors
to any data around the web.
So if the question is
do you connect to x,
the answer is usually yes.
For this, the
purpose of this demo,
we'll connect to BigQuery.
Like Soleil mentioned,
we have public data sets,
so I can come in here
and I can enrich my data
and my reports with
all the public data
sets that are
available on BigQuery.
But for this demo, we
have our retail data--
out test retail data.
So I select through there,
and then I just click connect.
And so what we're
doing right now
is we're making an underlying
connection to the underlying
data, and then now we
have all the fields
and the schema of these fields.
So what we've done
here is we've looked,
and we have autotyped
these fields.
So we know, for instance,
that month is a month due.
This is yyymmdd date.
And we also can come in here
and override some of these.
Like so for year
month, we didn't quite
get this one, so we'll
change this to year month.
And now, once we've done these
fixes in the data source,
we come here and
we create a report.
So we add our data
source to the report.
And now we can
just start drawing.
We click on the time series,
drag get across the page.
And just like that we
start visualizing data.
So for here, we want
to look at year month.
We'll just recreate the
demo that Maya made,
year month, and then
I search for revenue.
I pull in revenue here.
And now I'm looking at my
revenue over the last two
years.
And actually, let's also-- we
can adjust the page size here
so that it's the same size.
I think it was 800 by 400,
so that's a nice slide size.
We'll move this up, make
this a little smaller.
That's great, and
then I can start
adding controls onto this page.
So I can stick a
date range on here
and select a default date range.
We'll look at last year
for 2017 data only.
And then when I do operations on
this date control or any filter
controls that I put on the
page, they automatically
apply to all the
components on the page,
so there's no special
bindings that I have
to configure out of the box.
If I want to group
these together,
I can just select them
and group them together
so they only apply to these
specific visualizations.
So now let's keep going.
We can recreate.
We'll stick a scorecard
on here for revenue.
Great.
I should style this.
So I can come in here
and click on the chip,
change the format from
number to a currency.
So these are US dollars
and let's clean these
up, make these compact numbers.
Awesome.
And then we want to
look at this compared
to the previous period.
And we've invested a lot
in making the dates--
a lot of different functionality
and the dates very easy to use.
So for here, I can
just do last year.
I can compare this to
the previous period.
So now for any filter range
that I apply to this page,
we will look at that
for the previous period.
So if I want to look at
one week's worth of data,
we'll look at that same
week for the prior year,
or last quarter's worth of data,
we'll look at Q4 for last year
as well automatically.
So here I can go.
I've got revenue so
add a couple more.
We'll change this one to cost.
Great.
I've got costs.
And then we have another
one down here for profit--
profit dollars.
Awesome.
We'll move this one up.
And then so now I
want to create a field
for profit margin, which is
just profit dollars divided
by revenue.
So for here, I can create new
fields within the data source.
So I come in here
and I say profit--
we'll call this profit percent--
and then this is just profit
dollars divided by revenue.
And there's a lot of
different calculations
that we can make in here.
We can do use case
statements for grouping.
We can create hyperlinks
inside of tables.
We can concat fields together.
There's a lot of
different functionality
that we support within
this formula builder.
So here I create the field.
Awesome.
Got a new profit percentage.
It shows up immediately here.
I'll copy paste this.
Pull this over
profit percentage.
Now I want to show
this as a percentage.
So I just come in
here for the type.
I'll change the type to percent.
Great.
So now also this one--
if I recall correctly,
this was actually below.
So we'll move this
down, and then we'll
create a bar chart here.
See here, we can change this
to department and then this
to revenue.
And I'll change this to
a horizontal bar chart.
So now I need a little--
I can change the
margin here so that we
can see all of the labels.
Now I need a little help
because I don't actually
have the header, so
maybe my colleague Soleil
in a different
department actually
has all the right marketing.
So now what's really
cool is this is all
built on top of Google Drive.
So the same
technology that allows
users to collaborate
on other products
like Google Sheets
or Google Docs,
you can collaborate
inside of Data Studio
using that same technology.
So I come in here
to share the report.
And I'll share it
with Soleil dot demos.
Did I spell that correctly?
Soleil.demos@gmail.com.
Please help with
the brand logos.
So now Soleil's getting an
email notification in his box,
letting him know that he
can come in and actually
collaborate on this
report with me.
So, Soleil, can you go
ahead and click on that.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Yeah, let's
go ahead and open that up.
And is it untitled?
DAVE OLESON: Yeah,
untitled-- untitled report.
Think we're having slight issue.
I'll just keep going on here.
So now I'll come back here, and
I'll just grab the marketing
from the top myself.
Great.
I can grab this image.
Whoops.
Right here and then the
white background here.
And then just like you
can in any other design,
you can send this to the
back, pull this up to the top.
And I'll add a text field.
This Foo Hardware revenue.
Or Foo Hardware metrics.
So now I've created this
first slide on here,
showing exactly
what Maya has done.
And now it's really
easy to add-- let's just
add a title here, Foo Hardware.
Now it's really easy to add
the rest of the pages as well.
So I can add a new page.
Let's title this page
rename Metrics Overview.
And then page 2, we'll show--
let's see if I can remember.
We'll show the top five
states by top 5 states
department revenue breakdown.
So I will-- actually
I can come back here
in the metrics overview.
I can make all of these
elements report level.
So now these persists across
all the pages of my report,
so I don't have to
recreate them every time.
So great.
I have this, Foo
Hardware metrics.
I draw a bar chart.
I want to look at
our year month.
Year month broken
down by department.
And we'll look at
this by revenue.
We'll only look up the top
5, and we can switch this
to a horizontal.
And looks like the date
range is a little bit
too long so we'll add another
date range control here.
Excellent.
And make this set to last year.
Actually we can just
make this report level.
So we can go back
to our first page,
make this a report level--
make report level and now this
persists across both pages.
And I have my filters here, and
I should stack these bars up.
It looks like Soleil's on here.
So, Soleil, can you
go to page 2 here,
and can you change the
title for me on this page?
SOLEIL KELLEY: Yes,
of course, I can.
DAVE OLESON: So now I--
now see we see Soleil
up here on the screen,
and this red box here
shows that Soleil is actually
editing this in real time.
So this works, not
just if we're sitting--
standing next to each
other in a seminar,
but this also works if we're
on opposite sides of the world.
We can collaborate and edit
a report at the same time
together.
Now Soleil's fixing up
this bar chart together.
So we'll go.
I'll change the margin.
Moving it around.
I'll go work on the next page
while Soleil finishes this up.
Great.
Cool.
So now actually we'll
just make a copy
of this page, the top 5 states.
So I will come back here.
I'll duplicate this
one, copy of page 2.
Whoops.
Copied the wrong page.
So now I've got this, and
we want to look at this.
Let's order this by year
month under this year
month ascending.
Here we go.
Great.
And now I want to
create a filter for this
to look at the
category by paint only.
So now this isn't
a filter or control
that I want to allow my
users to switch around,
so I create this filter
at the report level.
So we'll call this
our paint filter,
include category
equal to, and we
have lots of different operators
that we can apply to filters.
So contain starts with--
we have red jacks.
And then we can also
create compound filters,
so we have both
ands and or filters
that you can use to create
very complex expressions.
So equal to paint
and we'll save this.
So now we're looking
at this paint.
This is paint only.
Let's break this
actually down by state.
So as you can see,
when I make a mistake,
it's very easy to go
and change it back
to get the right view of
data that I want to see.
So now Soleil is editing the
title there putting a-- oops.
I want not a text but a
box rectangle to show here.
I'll make this transparent.
I'll make a single
weight line of black,
and we'll make it dashed.
Cool.
And then if I hold
down the Shift key,
I can actually do very,
very small adjustments.
So now I've got my box showing
our awesome work right in here.
And then I can say, look
how well Paint performed.
Look how well Paint performed.
Awesome.
So then, again, if I just
want to do the same thing
and show this that this
is actually replicable,
I can duplicate this page again.
I come down here,
and then now it's
not paint that I want to look at
but appliances and the window.
So I create a new filter.
So we'll call this
one Appliances include
category equal to appliances.
I save this remove
the paint filter.
Then I just move this down,
get this aligned, click right.
And awesome.
Now I have my look how
well appliances performs.
So now I'm just about
10 or 15 minutes.
Soleil and I have recreated
this most of the demo
at least the data
within the demo.
And we've done
this all securely,
so we can go back here
to the metrics overview.
And now what really
cool, another feature
that we have within Data
Studio is the ability not just
to share these.
So I can now--
I could come in here, and
I could share this report
either with my executives,
point-to-point sharing,
or I could actually share
this with a Google Group.
So let's say there is a metric
overview group at my company.
I could share this with them,
and they would automatically
have access to go in and
look at this dashboard.
And there's different levels
of access that I can give them.
So with Soleil,
I gave him access
to be able to edit so
we could collaborate
in real time on this report.
But I also, just like Google
sheet or a Google doc,
I can only give view access
so that when people come in
here all they're able to do,
they can't mess up my report.
They can come in
here and all they
can do is interact with the
filters that I put on the page.
But there's another
distribution model
that we have beyond just
point-to-point sharing where
I can go in here,
and I can enable
embedding of this report.
So now this is a private
report as Soleil mentioned.
So we can embed this
in our internal website
so that people can
come in on the wiki
and be able to see
what we've created
from within our own site.
So I'll just quickly show how
to do this on a Google site.
So I'll grab this link.
I'll come in here.
This is of my site's name
Foo Hardware's West Coast
Marketing.
This is what I
showed on my bosses
when I want to get promoted.
I come in here.
I stick the embed link in here.
I insert here.
So this is our overview page.
And so now I can
also add a text box
and say check out how well
Paint did in the spring.
Then I come back here.
I go to page--
see here--
SOLEIL KELLEY: Page 5.
DAVE OLESON: Page 5.
Great.
I grab this embed URL.
I embed this in here.
And then this is my Paint page.
So it's really cool is I come
in here to preview this data.
So this is what it would
look like to my stakeholders.
And they would actually
be able to come in here
and interact with any filters
that I put on the page.
So not only is this a report
that I can share with people,
but this is I a live
interactive application
that I can embed inside of my
company's own wiki or block.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Kind of
here and if I made changes
to the report over time to--
basically refreshing
the page, those
changes would be
reflected here, too.
DAVE OLESON: Yeah, so we
could actually look at this.
Let's say we came here,
and we went to page 1.
And I said, oh, I don't
want to look at last year.
I want to look at the
year before, for instance.
Or let's just say I don't want
to show this profit percentage,
and I don't want to
show this revenue.
I just want to show--
really want to keep the focus
on the revenue breakdown
by department.
And then I come back in here.
And if I refresh this page
and go into preview mode,
now this report has-- or
this application actually
that I've created has
updated in real time
to reflect the latest changes
that I made on my report.
SOLEIL KELLEY:
That's super cool.
Thanks for walking
through the demo, Dave.
DAVE OLESON: Yeah, no problem.
SOLEIL KELLEY: I had a little--
demo gods were
not quite with us.
I didn't realize
what was going on.
I was in a different account
instead of the soleil.demos.
In any case, really
great application
of being able to create these
data stories and publish them
internally or externally.
Powerful tool that--
it can tell it
really simplifies the process
in just a few minutes.
It's pretty straightforward to
be able to create those stories
and find whatever insights you
want to share and send those
out to folks.
So obviously we
encourage all of you
to go try Data Studio
itself as well.
Again, it's a free
product, so it's
really easy to just
click around and explore,
connect up to your own data.
If you'd like, you
can import that where
it can connect to some of the
public data sets and BigQuery.
And we urge you all
to go explore that.
And with that,
thank you so much.
I just wanted to let you
know people have been asking
some questions throughout this
presentation in our live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
about less than a minute
or to answer some of
those questions live.
So stay tuned, and we'll
be right back with that.
Great.
Welcome back to our
live Q&A portion
of Cloud OnAir at Google Cloud.
Dave, we got a bunch of great
questions from the audience.
Our moderator has popped
those into a slide for us
to be able to see.
We get a ton of great
questions over time.
This is actually a pretty
common one as well.
The first one how do people
join different data sets
in Data Studio?
DAVE OLESON: So right now, we
don't have support for joins
within Data Studio.
This is something we're
actively working on,
so look for this
in the near future.
The workaround right now is to
pump your data into BigQuery
and do the join actually
inside of BigQuery
and then visualize that
inside of Data Studio.
SOLEIL KELLEY: What would
I need to be able to do
within BigQuery to do that?
DAVE OLESON: So just write
a simple SQL join statement
in BigQuery.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Great.
How about viewing dashboards
on mobile devices?
DAVE OLESON: Yes.
So you can view dashboards
on mobile devices.
You just have to scale
them down because we
offer a lot of flexibility in
what you can put on the page.
So obviously you can't
have as much granularity
on a mobile device.
So what we've seen
people do is scale down
the number of controls
that are on the page
to be able to
visualize and access
that information on mobile.
SOLEIL KELLEY: That
makes a ton of sense.
And then again using
this internally,
what access control
features does
Data Studio support
for dashboards
and also the underlying data?
Where does that data reside?
DAVE OLESON: So the
underlying data always
relies on the
underlying data system,
and there's multiple off
models that we support.
So Data Studio is built
on top of Google Drive.
So-- versus like you'd share
a sheet or a Google doc.
That's how we-- you would share
a Google Data Studio report.
Now for the underlying
data, there's
different access
models for connecting
to the data using both owner's
credentials and viewer's
credentials.
So if you set viewer's
credentials on a data source,
then everyone who has access--
everyone who wants to
render that data in a report
will have to have access
to the underlying data
because they will be using
their credentials to query
the underlying system.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Makes sense.
Cool.
Thank you.
And then what about connecting
to external data sources?
We brought this up in
the slides actually.
What is it?
DAVE OLESON: Sure, yeah.
So we connect to a lot of--
this is a common question.
We connect to a lot of
Google data sources--
Google ads data and
Google cloud data.
We also connect to on prem
data like MySQL and Postgres.
And then we have--
we're growing an ecosystem to
connect to all sorts of data
around the web.
So we have over 300 connections
to different data sources
around the web, and
that's constantly growing.
So if we don't have
it, you actually
can go and build it yourself.
We've had our UX team.
Even our director has built
simple connectors and prototype
connectors in under an hour.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Cool.
That's great.
And then talk a little bit
more about how filters work
and the different elements
that you can filter by.
DAVE OLESON: Sure.
Yes.
So we have multiple
types of filters.
So there's filters
which I showed,
which are on the page, which
you can have at the page level,
at the report level,
or you can even
buy into specific elements.
So I could say, I only want
to filter this one graph
by department, and then
I want to compare it
against my overall
revenue in another chart.
We also have filters that exist
at what we call the report
level or the editor level.
So the editors sets
those, and they
support red jacks,
exclusion, end filters,
greater than or less than
operators for metric filters,
and then we also
have ands and ors.
So there's a lot of
flexibility in our filtering.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Great.
And then finally, exporting to
PDF, tell us more about this.
DAVE OLESON: You can--
this is a common request.
There is a single
page export to PDF.
If you are in Chrome, you
can use the file print
to print to PDF.
And this is something
that we're looking
into for later this year.
SOLEIL KELLEY: Excellent.
And that concludes
our live Q&A portion.
These were the top questions
that were bubbled up in our--
throughout the presentation.
So thank you so
much for joining us.
Make sure you stay tuned
for the next section.
It's called Building
for Growth--
The Future of Transactional
Data Platforms and System.
It's been a ton of fun here.
Thanks, Dave, for
doing all the demoing.
DAVE OLESON: Thanks, Soleil.
SOLEIL KELLEY: And thanks again.
We'll talk to you soon.